[Musique]
à
nous
au coeur d'une grande et belle forêt une
gentille famille de crédits sauvage
l'yvette en paix qu'est ce que c'est 10
soit casqués armés de seuil et de haches
montesson des bulldozer attaque la forêt
[Musique]
à batna
pour faire place à une autoroute
[Musique]
apeurée la famille de crédits sauvage
d'état là tout net
oui de quel côté qu'ils aillent des
machines terrifiante se dresse devant
tôt
[Musique]
allez allez un petit effort
bush s'en est fallu de peu
mais hélas il est trop tard les machines
barre la route et le petit credo se
trouve désormais séparé de sa famille
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
de l'autre côté de l'autoroute
la maman credo il désespérer
[Musique]
ça y est l'autoroute est terminée
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et petit matou bateau se transforme en
pompe les ouvriers n'arriverons à rien
et pensons d'un bois très résistant
[Rires]
heureusement tout finit bien
rabattus par les ouvriers le petit
crédit se dirige vers l'autoroute
tu peux maintenant traverser grâce au
pont et voici la famille de crédits
sauvage de nouveau réunis au revoir à
tous à tous et merci
il
tous
et